let me read a little bit from this
article from nbc news and then we'll
just we'll talk about it
nbc reports china proposes teaching
masculinity to boys as state is alarmed
by changing gender roles boys in china
traditionally are expected to be strong
leaders
get good grades and excel at sports but
the gender balance in china is changing
they say they start with this like i
hate when journalists do this out with a
story
no one invited boo younhau to be in
their group for the annual class trip
the other fifth graders at shanghai
shangdi experimental school
made fun of the 11 year old calling him
too girly quote i wanted to run away
right out of the classroom said young
hao now 13 in a first year middle
schooler in shanghai
some of his classmates made fun of his
high-pitched voice and the way he
screamed when he tried to maintain
discipline
among his fellow students as a class
monitor others teased him for spending
so much time with the girls
and said he acted like he was trying to
date the other boys in the class
the bullying eventually stopped but a
recent announcement by the government
that singles out boys who don't fit
traditional chinese
ideas of masculinity has revived the
painful memories
the plan to quote encourage masculinity
in male students
has inflamed a debate over modern gender
roles
as china's government increasingly
emphasizes what many consider to be
outdated
and damaging stereotypes for men and
boys
i think it's interesting because that
that perspective is wholly american
like in america it's very much i'm
reading the story and it's like if that
happened now there would be a
psa they'd bring in bully experts and
then say no no it's okay that he's
effeminate and things like that
but it also reminds me of that
commercial that we saw in out of china a
while ago where they put the black men
in the washing machine
and he comes out as chinese people in
the united states were outraged how dare
you you're so racist
people in china laughed and didn't seem
to care at all so i i wonder what your
guys thought i don't know whoever wants
to jump in
about uh you know the gender roles in
china and what you guys think is
happening well one thing that jumps to
mind is you know back in the
cultural revolution uh it was sort of
the opposite where
they were making an effort to like
completely eliminate any kind of
gender like the women had to dress in uh
almost like military attire very baggy
had to have
short haircuts uh any kind of display of
femininity was
not allowed and now similar now i guess
right
uh well i think the women are allowed to
be and
encouraged and that reminds me of the
guy who had a was found out to have 100
mistresses
i think he won he wanted them to be very
feminine still ah
he got executed by the way well that
escalated quickly
it did well i mean there's also a lot of
corruption so it wasn't
yeah it was also the three metric tons
of cash they found in
oh okay okay yeah the problem was like a
guy who's like i want a bunch of women
off with his head
no no word on what happened i believe it
though yeah i don't know where the
mistresses are but yeah shelly you made
a good point about sort of the influence
of
south korea on china yeah i think the
thing is that with
the growing like k-pop cave dramas like
this whole korean wave coming and like
th
there has been kind of more like
the a more effeminate kind of male has
been like
the uh ideal in movies and
music and all this stuff and it's
affected china a lot
and in response the chinese communist
party tried to basically have their own
like patriotic boy bands and
chaotic they love that one yeah and then
it's it didn't quite
work well but they're trying to like
basically use
um like chinese culture to fight this
like
incoming korean like popular culture
that they didn't like
and then you've also got this so like in
chinese the word for like
the type of like effeminate like male
like these like really pretty young men
is called like small soft meat like
small
tender meat all right so that's so
that's become like super hot and then
the chinese communist party is like
that's not
masculine enough meanwhile the chinese
communist party is making movies like
wolf warrior right
like they want like the chinese rambo
that's really it's really weird though i
mean they're communist
and then in the united states the the
right criticizes all of this stuff by
saying
those trying to strip away masculinity
are communists right so we had jack
murphy on the show recently
and he went uh uh you know he went on
this tirade about
marxism is inherently anti-masculine
because they want to get rid of the
patriarchy and things like that
but how does that make sense that the
communist party of china wants
strong burly masculine men and they're
literally
the communist party it's like well there
are different
different tactics to communism and in a
communist country like china
they want a big fearsome military that
intimidates
other countries uh china is definitely
gearing up for the day
they invade taiwan they've been very
open about
wanting to invade taiwan they've said
this for decades and so
i think this is partially a response to
like creating an
image internationally of like this is a
fearsome military force that will be
able
to uh take taiwan don't mess with it in
the south china sea
but but does this have anything to do
with what's happening in the u.s are
they responding to
what's happening here i know you guys
mentioned korea right
is it isn't a lot of what happens in
korea related to
you know they want to sell to america
they they like the culture that america
exports they try to adopt certain things
like that
like boy bands weren't invented in in
korea yeah
they i don't know if they were invented
here in america mind you well uh k-pop
they definitely were obviously inspired
by the american music industry but i
think they've been
fairly unsuccessful at really
penetrating the u.s market
outside of like uh bts or like gangnam
style
which was but sai isn't like
he's not the typical he's not a bts
right he's not a serious it's like very
hokey and silly and like he's making fun
of it kind of yeah so i don't know you
can say that like
uh that korean style is appealing to the
us because it really hasn't
done that yet yeah even though there's a
lot of good k-pop out no but i mean like
is korea trying to be like the us in
terms of how pop culture works right
they're
they're emulating a lot of countries do
this america has some kind of pop
culture phenomenon and then you know
they emulate it
i mean we emulate a bit of the british
stuff too when we've had various
different artists come from the uk
i'm just wondering if china's reaction
to this and and the things they're doing
is countering the united states right
like i was saying about the communist
thing they're looking at
are they looking at the u.s and being
like we're going to do the opposite of
what the u.s is because the us is bad
how kind of like how tribalism works i
actually think they're kind of trying to
do the same thing that the us did but in
like the 80s
like they want to use you know
soft power to project like the way that
you know american blue jeans or
brought up a rambo right like like us
this
or top gun like these type of like um
movies that like
celebrated they love top cop in china
like this kind of
masculinity that that kind of like power
like that appeals to the communist party
because that seems like
it's like oh then you have the power to
like wolf warrior was about
you know these chinese uh soldiers who
went to rescue chinese citizens
who were you know in africa right so
like they were
uh you know the whole idea was like the
motherland will never leave you behind
like it was this like whole like very
patriotic yeah it's like 80s
yeah yeah and and the whole idea like
the communist party uses the propaganda
of the century of humiliation
constantly the idea that you know
foreign forces have humiliated the west
and so china needs to be strong we need
to be strong and
fight against uh the hostile foreign
forces
so what do you think the sentiment among
the chinese people is though
i mean it doesn't really sound like the
communist party is communist
that's a big conversation so you know
there's a lot of elements to communism
and a lot of people think
oh communism is about the the government
says here's what products have to be
made and who does what jobs
right and i think that's that's true but
that's only at you know
five percent of what communism is you
know ultimately communism is about
power and control for the communist
party and so they'll use these ideas of
creating a utopia on earth and and you
know you know how it goes
uh it ends up you know they promise
equity they promise equality
uh and ultimately you know some animals
are a lot more equal than others right
that is the leadership of the party
um what we see in china is a
there's a lot of capitalism going on in
the sense you have a lot of private
industry now and you have in the last 40
plus years since the
geiger kai fung that reform and opening
up from started in 1978
huge explosion in private industries but
the reason china is still
completely a communist country is number
one
the communist party actually controls
all those private industries
so uh you've got uh you know alibaba
uh you know the uh dalian wanda the film
company you know any any company has to
have a communist party branch
in the company that's even funded by a
company and they're involved in
big decisions that are happening in the
company in fact even foreign companies
that go into china like mcdonald's ikea
they all have
party cells in the country by law they
have to have party cells in the company
and so there's there's that control of
private industry on top of that
you've got some of the the biggest
industries in china that are directly
state-owned enterprises steel coal
telecommunications some of the
construction
so so that element is communist and then
on top of that
you've got the sort of communist
legal system which is that they don't
have the kind of legal system we think
of here you've got obviously the rubber
stamp congress
but you also have the way that they rule
is not through rule of law
they have they rule through these mass
political
campaigns which is you know a whole
other topic but
like simply put you know xi jinping will
say something like
you know we need to improve the quality
of
public toilets in china and then like
everyone in china has to get involved in
like
sprucing up these things and some local
officials go nuts and they build these
like
you know million dollar golden toilets
you know for for foreign look how
great we're following this this policy
this political but it's a political
campaign
you know private companies have to do it
local officials and you get promoted
based on how well you
follow the policy and even if the policy
is is ludicrous or even if you take it
to an extreme
that doesn't matter because you know
you're as a local official you're not
accountable
to voters you're accountable only to the
higher-ups who are giving you your
position
so in that sense it's it's still
completely communist even though you
it seems to have the elements of
capitalism who was it michael bloomberg
who said something about how xi jinping
has uh his constituents he has to
oh yeah he said not a dictator right
yeah yeah he's not a dictator yeah all
right so
so he doesn't you say he doesn't have
voters michael bloomberg disagrees
sort of i mean is there a possibility
that
if the people are upset xi jinping will
not be in power well let's ask the
uyghurs
[Laughter]
i don't i don't think that like but like
there is like there is you know this
whole populism versus the elites thing
that's happening basically all around
the world
uh in china the communist party is like
uniquely positioned to take advantage of
it because they're a communist party so
they already
say you know it's the people's this the
people's that but xi jinping has
specifically
made an attempt to be a populist leader
within the communist party even
so he'll do things like his
anti-corruption campaign which was
really about kind of
getting rid of his political enemies but
a lot of it was
positioned as like we're getting rid of
like the excessive
like elite communist members who are
just
you know wasting money and drinking and
having mistresses and those kind of
stuff
and then he'll be photographed you know
uh
take eating steamed buns at a like an
ordinary restaurant with the common
people
or like you know these kind of like very
guy you could have a buy joe with
yeah like he's a guy you could eat a
steamed bun with it's like very like
maoist in that way
or it's like man of the people type of
propaganda so he's
making a specific play to become the
populist leader
i think prior probably partly because of
the the power struggle that's going on
within the party
so he kind of understands that like
having he needs to have
you know the ordinary people on his side
quote-unquote yeah well that's what
drove the cultural revolution mao was
kind of on the outs
he used the love of the people
particularly the psychotic young youth
activated them and then he was
back in power basically that's powerful
do regular people in china like
generally speaking the communist party
or xi jinping well they'll certainly say
so publicly
hard to really know what the opinion is
because there there is no
forum that they can really actually
clubhouse was kind of an interesting
example
of um maybe some signs of dissent like
clubhouse
uh there were mandarin language chat
rooms that would like
very very quickly fill up to like their
five thousand person
max capacity and this was like for a
very brief window i think it was only
about a week
or so the club it was the weekend it was
a weekend
when i shut it down it was just like
this little bit of crack where
people inside mainland china could have
actual uncensored access to the outside
world wow
and they were talking about xinjiang and
the uyghurs and the concentration camps
and
all this stuff they were hearing from
uyghurs they were hearing from people in
hong kong in taiwan
and so i think that was a that's a sign
that people in china
are aware on some level that they are
being starved
of information yeah and they're going
for it but also people on clubhouse like
you're talking about you know
wealthy chinese people or upper upper
middle class yeah
rural farmers you know yes exactly yeah
i mean my experience mainly with
overseas chinese people
is that they've generally been seem to
be positive towards the communist party
and i think that's a lot a lot of times
because you have a
very small subset of people that end up
making it
to the united states uh and the reason
they got their wealth so they could come
here is actually because
they had connections within the party
and many of them
were party members themselves and so so
you've got like a very
a small and non-representative subset of
wealthy or influential overseas chinese
who are saying
we like the communist party or they'll
say oh maybe there's a few
issues but basically it's been really
good for china well you're talking about
the people who have come here within the
last like
10 years last 10 years right and so but
then you have like
if what you're really talking about is
the other 1.3 billion
chinese people you may have a very
different perspective and i remember
shelley when you were talking with blind
chinese
rights lawyer chen guangcheng about what
was on the ground in china yeah and he
talked about how
you know many people are very fed up
with the chinese communist party they
just cannot express it online because
they know i mean people have been
arrested in china for
calling xi jinping a steamed bun for
example or winnie the pooh right yeah
yeah so it's not it's not a joke that
like people are
seriously getting in trouble for what
they say online yeah yeah well it's
happening here now
just in different ways i think it's
interesting how we've basically just
outsourced censorship
very different from what they do i mean
for them it's the communist party that
dictates the censorship right
here it's just oh oh we we can't
interfere with what the monopoly
wants so now you look at how every all
the conversations here are being
controlled
it seems like there are there are
parallels not completely identical
but still some similarities where people
are getting you know it's getting worse
and worse here well tim they're private
companies they have the right to you
know monitor their own businesses
don't you support billion dollar
conglomerates like google
see that's the issue it's it's always
the centralized power
if we give all the power to the
government you'll end up with a similar
problem
however we have a bill of rights in this
country so there's at least that to
protect us
in the event that in the us we say okay
we're going to nationalize or regulate
these companies
but you'll still run the risk no matter
what the supreme power is the
the centralized unified authority no
matter what it's
what it is it's going to tell you you
can't do things it doesn't like
well i mean the foundation of the united
states is the idea that absolute power
corrupts absolutely so it's a system
in place to prevent the elite from
getting
too much power because what always
happens is the people who become elite
think they should have more power
and have a general disdain for all of us
other schlubs yeah but but they know
better than us chris
shouldn't we let them tell us what to do
and what to think
my problem with the elite is they don't
recognize that i should be amongst them
yeah right yeah jerks i know i have a
very high iq i'm sure
my mom told me yes yeah well
to to islam to a certain extent i mean
the communist party is just the elite
the people who choose to join it do
they're doing so because they know they
will get
the elite ranks the privilege the access
they use they use the same line that uh
communism has used all along that
there's class struggle uh
the world would be a better place if
there weren't this group oppressing
everyone else
uh and so they are the people and then
they
uh kill everyone they well they kill
they kill the bad people
and then take over and then obviously
since they're the good
guys they can do whatever they want and
everyone has to that's right
and it's hard when you uh get into power
uh
on the premise that you're fighting
those in power
because then you don't want people to
fight the power when you become the
power
right well then they just have to to
come up with a group to target
right so you know you target the
students in 1989 and they become the
pariahs and you massacre them there's
always some enemy to fight
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you